This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Wars. Oh God! Thank you, thank you, thank you! My whole Dan life has been worth it. Yes for this moment. So I was once walking the city with my friend Kathleen, who is an environmental scientist, and she was pointing out the spray painted markings of letters and arrows that you see everywhere on the street. The markings indicate where utility lines are running underground so they're not damaged by construction. And it turns out they're color-coded by the American Public Works Association. Red's spray paint means electrical power lines and yellow is natural gas.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。哦，天哪！谢谢，谢谢，谢谢！我这辈子活得值了。为了这一刻，这一切都值了。所以，我曾经和我的朋友凯瑟琳一起在城市里散步，她是一名环境科学家，她向我指出街道上随处可见的用喷漆画上的字母和箭头。这些标记指示了地下公用管线的位置，以免它们在施工中受到损坏。事实证明，这些颜色是由美国公共工程协会统一编码的。红色的喷漆代表电力线，黄色代表天然气。
And I'm looking this up now on Wikipedia because I don't remember all the details. Green means sewage and drainage lines. So public works people and construction crews have their own low-fi, augmented reality scribbled right on the street, like a giant map in plain sight. It's a different way to see the city. But it's not just utility workers. The city also reads differently depending on your knowledge, your experience, or if you happen to be standing on a rolling plank of wood.
我现在正在维基百科上查阅这个，因为我记不全所有的细节。绿色代表污水和排水管道。因此，公共工程人员和施工人员将他们自己的低保真增强现实涂鸦直接喷在街上，就像一幅显眼巨型地图。这是看待城市的一种不同方式。但不仅限于公用设施工人。根据你的知识、经验，或者碰巧你正站在一块滚动的木板上，这座城市呈现出的面貌也各不相同。
I've been lucky enough to go to these amazing places like Taiwan or LA, but I only ever get to see the weird places that skaters go to, like industrial parks or some handrail in the middle of a school somewhere. That's our guide today, skateboard photographer and radio reporter Andrew Norton. My friend Ariel and I are skating in downtown Toronto, kind of carving through the big empty corporate plazas. It's hard with a backpack. I'll give you one of these though. To a skateboarder, the city looks different. Something I definitely always do is, um, just look for opportunities to escape when I can't.
我很幸运能去到台湾或洛杉矶这样神奇的地方，但我去过的地方只限于滑板手常去的那些奇怪场所，比如工业园区或某个学校中间的扶手。这就是我们今天的向导，滑板摄影师兼电台记者安德鲁·诺顿。我和我的朋友阿里尔正在多伦多市中心玩滑板，在那些巨大空旷的商业广场里穿梭。背着背包很难做到这一点。不过我送你一个这个。对滑手来说，这座城市看起来是不一样的。我绝对一直在做的一件事是，嗯，就是在无法逃离时寻找逃离的机会。
I can't help myself. We can possibly look for things like ledges or curb cuts, mundane stuff that people walk right past. But to escape order, even a pole that's been bent by a car is a thing to escape. So you're always on the hunt. Like, I'll make my wife stop the car if I see something new. Dude, I even like, I even when I'm watching movies
我情不自禁。我们可能会寻找诸如矮墙或路缘石之类的东西，这些都是人们直接走过、平淡无奇的东西。但为了摆脱秩序，甚至连被汽车撞弯的电线杆也是可以用来逃离的对象。所以你总是在寻找目标。比如，如果我看到什么新鲜的东西，我会让我妻子把车停下来。老兄，甚至连我，我甚至在看电影的时候
we'll be looking for spots. Ha ha ha, you look for spots in movies? Whoa, Andrew. Like, I've watched the Simpsons and I'm like, you could skate that hubbub. You know what? I guess I do that too. Wait, what's a hubbub?
我们都会寻找适合滑板的地点。哈哈，你在电影里找滑板地点？哇，安德鲁。比如，我看《辛普森一家》时就会想，你可以在那个台阶上玩滑板。你知道吗？我想我也这么做。等等，什么是“hubba”？
A hubbub is what skaters call a ledge that runs down a flight of stairs parallel to the stairs. And it's named after a famous spot in San Francisco called hubba hideout. Hubba is slang for crack. So I guess people used to hang out, they're used to gather there to smoke crack. It's particularly skateboard worthy.
Hubba是滑手们对沿着楼梯延伸并与楼梯平行的矮墙（ledge）的称呼。它以旧金山一个著名的滑板圣地命名，叫做Hubba Hideout（哈巴避难所）。Hubba是瘾君子的俚语。所以我想以前人们经常去那里聚会吸毒。这个地方特别适合玩滑板。
Yeah, because it's this perfect ledge that runs parallel down the flight of stairs. I mean, ask any skater go to any skate park, you know, every skater will know what a hubba is. And that is how I'm going to exclusively refer to them from now on. I'm always looking for things like that. Black wax, caked on a ledge, or wheel marks on a wall.
是的，因为这是一堵沿着楼梯平行延伸的完美矮墙。我的意思是，问问任何一个滑手，去任何一个滑板公园，你知道的，每个滑手都知道什么是Hubba。从今以后，我将只用这个词来称呼它们。我总是在寻找这样的东西。厚厚涂在矮墙上的黑色蜡，或者墙上的轮印。
These are little breadcrumb trails left by my people. And once you start following these trails, they'll lead you to a turf war between the city and the skaters. Oh, this spot here. Have you ever skated these? This has long been known as a spot to meet up. And more recently, they put some stoppers on it to prevent people from skating. So a skate stopper is anything that someone might add to something we'd want to skateboard on
这些是我同类留下的一小串面包屑。一旦你开始沿着这些小径寻找，它们就会把你带入城市与滑手之间的地盘之争。哦，这地方。你在这上面玩过滑板吗？这里长期以来一直是一个聚会的好地方。最近，他们在这里安装了一些防滑装置，以防止人们在这里滑板。因此，防滑装置是指人们可能会加装在我们想要玩滑板的东西上的任何东西
to stop us from skateboarding on it. So in this case, on these long, kind of S-shaped granite benches that we're looking at, they put strips of granite kind of running the width of the bench so that we can't ride along the top of it. Normally people would be sliding on this and then get this or grinding on this and then come to a stop against these. I imagine most people don't know what they're there for. So as skateboarders, I think we're hypersensitive and very aware of these small things that get added.
用来阻止我们在上面玩滑板。所以在这种情况下，在我们看到的这些长长的、某种S型的花岗岩长椅上，他们加装了贯穿长椅宽度的花岗岩条，这样我们就无法在顶部滑行了。通常人们会在上面做滑行（sliding），或者做 grinding（卡板滑行）然后在这些障碍物前停下来。我想大多数人不知道这些东西是用来做什么的。所以作为滑手，我认为我们对这些新增的小东西高度敏感且非常清楚。
Well, one of the most traditional type of thing you'll see will be some kind of a metal peg or raised metal attachment that is either built into a wall or attached to a wall afterwards. And what that does is it creates a discontinuous edge. Tony Bricoli is an architect from Philadelphia. He's fascinated with how skaters interact with the city. And though he's not a skateboarder himself, Tony's always kept tabs on the types of anti-skating measures the city can deploy.
嗯，你将看到的最传统的类型之一是某种金属钉或凸起的金属附件，它们要么内置在墙里，要么事后附着在墙上。它的作用是制造出一个不连续的边缘。托尼·布里科利是来自费城的建筑师。他对外行滑手如何与城市互动很着迷。尽管他自己不是滑手，但托尼一直密切关注城市可以部署的各种防滑措施。
And then it gets more extreme and more ridiculous where the companies that sell things that look like metal seashells and metal crabs that I guess for some reason that's meant to be more aesthetically pleasing, I don't know. Those aesthetically pleasing skate stoppers are all around the Embarcad'Aro in San Francisco. To Tony, the reason why modern cities
然后情况变得更加极端，更加荒谬，那些出售看起来像金属贝壳和金属螃蟹的公司的产品，我猜出于某种原因，这旨在更具美观性，我不知道。那些美观的防滑装置在旧金山的内河码头（Embarcadero）随处可见。对托尼来说，为什么现代城市
are so perfect for skateboarding, goes back to a French dude named Lake Corbusier. Tony Bracale wrote an essay called Thanks, Look a Bousier, from the skateboarders. In it, he intends that Look a Bousier as the platonic ideal of the modernist architect with his cool glasses and love of concrete is the patron saint of skateboarders. Modernists were the ones that reinterpreted a bench in a park as a slab of granite.
如此完美地适合滑板，这要追溯到一个名叫勒·柯布西耶的法国人。托尼·布拉卡莱为滑手们写了一篇题为《谢谢你，勒·柯布西耶》的文章。在文中，他将勒·柯布西耶视为现代主义建筑师的柏拉图式理想，他戴着酷炫的眼镜，热爱混凝土，是滑手们的守护神。现代主义者是将公园里的长椅重新诠释为花岗岩板的人。
Reinterpreted, you know, kind of flowing landscapes, grassy areas as these kind of paved open plaza spaces. And it just turned out that wide open space with nice gran at ledges at the edge made really good skateboarding space. And who would have known? The prime example of modernist landscape architecture that's inadvertently perfect for skateboarding is Philadelphia's love park. It's real name is JFK Plaza, but it's called love park after Robert and Yana's giant love statue with that slanted O that was put there for the United States by Centennial. In the center of Philadelphia's City Hall and if you draw a line from City Hall to the Art Museum there's a diagonal boulevard that connects the two and along that axis is where
重新诠释了，你知道的，那种流动的景观、草地，变成了这种铺砌的开放式广场空间。事实证明，宽阔的开放空间边缘配有漂亮的花岗岩矮墙，构成了非常好的滑板空间。谁能想到呢？无意中完美适合滑板的现代主义景观建筑的典型例子是费城的爱公园（Love Park）。它的真名是肯尼迪广场（JFK Plaza），但为了纪念罗伯特和亚娜的巨大“LOVE”雕塑，由于其倾斜的“O”字是为了美国双百节而放置在那里的，因此被称为爱公园。它位于费城市政厅的正中心，如果你画一条从市政厅到艺术博物馆的线，有一条对角线大道连接着这两者，沿着这条轴线就是
Love Park was placed. The two tiered plaza takes up an entire city block. In the center, long, wide steps cascade down to a giant circular fountain. Above on the main level, granite planters surround the plaza as well as lots of rectangular and marble benches. It's a space only a modernist or a skateboarder could love. And it's awesome for skating because you can do what we call lines, which is like a series of tricks. So you could do like a switch crook on one of the benches and then a fakey tray flip.
爱公园所在地。这座两层的广场占了整整一个街区。在中央，长而宽的台阶呈瀑布般倾泻而下，通向一个巨大的圆形喷泉。上方的主层上，花岗岩花坛环绕着广场，还有许多长方形的大理石长椅。这是一个只有现代主义者或滑手才会喜欢的空间。它非常适合滑板，因为你可以做我们称之为“连招”（lines）的动作，就像是一系列技巧。所以你可以在其中一个长椅上做一个 switch crook（反脚内侧大招），然后做一个 fakie tre flip（倒滑360大乱）。
And then if you wanted to, you could do like a switchback tail on another part of the park. Oh, and the granite tiles can even be pried up to make little ramps to launch off. The park was conceived for the late Edmund Bacon as part of his undergraduate thesis at Cornell. He later made the park a reality as the executive director of the Philadelphia City Planning
如果你想的话，你可以在公园的另一个地方做一个 switchback tail（反脚尾滑）。哦，花岗岩瓷砖甚至可以被撬起来做成可以借力起跳的小坡道。这个公园是由已故的埃德蒙·培根（Edmund Bacon）作为他在康奈尔大学本科毕业论文的一部分构思的。后来，在建筑师文森特·克林（Vincent Kling）的帮助下，他作为费城城市规划委员会的执行主任，将这座公园变成了现实。
Commission with the help of architect Vincent Kling. Ed's been a big deal in the architecture world since the 50s when he shaped how Philly looks today. His vision for the city even put him on the cover of Time Magazine. He also happens to be the father of Kevin Bacon, really. Now you're one level away from Kevin because you're talking to me, though,
自50年代塑造了费城今天的面貌以来，埃德在建筑界一直是个大人物。他对这座城市的设计愿景甚至让他登上了《时代》周刊的封面。他碰巧还是凯文·培根的父亲，真的。现在你离凯文只有一步之遥，因为你在跟我说话，虽然
and I'm actually waiting, that'd be two, right? Actually, I think that's four degrees. This is the closest I've been in that game. This is very exciting. So there you go, my friend. I'm happy I could help you there. Bacon's designed turned out to be perfect for skateboarding. And then the 80s, when skating took to the streets,
我其实在等，那是两步，对吧？其实，我认为那是四度。这是我在那个游戏中离得最近的一次。这太令人兴奋了。所以你看，我的朋友。我很很高兴我能在那里帮到你。培根的设计最终证明非常适合滑板运动。然后在80年代，当滑板运动走上街头时，
the timing was perfect for skaters to claim love park as their own. You know, there was kind of suburb to migration. There was less interest in density. And so places like Love Park were kind of sitting there, not being used. In the early 90s, skaters started filming themselves at Love Park. And the videos found their way to the epicenter of the skate world, California. Suddenly Philadelphia was a destination for skaters.
时机对滑手们来说是完美的，他们将爱公园占为己有。你知道的，当时有一种向郊区迁移的趋势。对人口密度的兴趣降低了。因此像爱公园这样的地方就那样闲置着，没有被使用。在90年代初，滑手们开始在爱公园拍摄自己的视频，这些视频最终流传到了滑板世界的中心——加利福尼亚。突然间，费城成了滑手们向往的目的地。
And as the skateboarding industry grew, so did the popularity of Love Park. By the late 90s, pro skaters moved to Philly just to skate it every day. They built their career shooting photos for glossy skateboard magazines of the park. You could even virtually skate there in Tony Hawk's famous video game.
随着滑板产业的发展，爱公园的知名度也随之水涨船高。到了90年代末，职业滑手们搬到费城，只为了每天都在这里滑板。他们通过为光鲜亮丽的滑板杂志拍摄该公园的照片来开启自己的职业生涯。你甚至可以在托尼·霍克著名的电子游戏中虚拟滑板。
So as an awkward 14 year old passing through Philly on vacation, I was like, Dad, we gotta go to Love Park. So I got to skate the ledges and stairs I saw in videos and on my PlayStation. While my dad read the newspaper by the fountain. I wouldn't be that excited again until I got my braces off. Even though Love Park was like Mecca, it was never legal to skate there. I don't think it's legal to skate at Mecca either.
因此，作为一个在度假路过费城的尴尬14岁少年，我说：“爸爸，我们必须去爱公园。”于是我得以在视频中和我的 PlayStation 上看到的矮墙和楼梯上玩滑板。而我爸爸则坐在喷泉旁边看报纸。直到我摘下牙套之前，我再也没有那么兴奋过。尽管爱公园就像是麦加圣地，但在那里滑板从来都不是合法的。我想在麦加滑板大概也是不合法的吧。
Skaters would get tackled by cops, ticketed by undercoverers, or have their boards taken away. The ship's off the way. We're going to be on the way. We're going to be on the way. We're going to be on the way. And the area was gentrifying.
滑手们会被警察扑倒，遭到便衣警察的罚款，或者滑板被没收。船已经开走了。我们要出发了。我们要出发了。我们要出发了。而且这个地区正在经历中产阶级化。
Finally, in 2002, Philly Mayor John Street took the skateboard band a step further and renovated the park. The major thing that they did was they removed all of the granite benches, these great skateable elements, and they replaced them with, you know, kind of, um, Williams and Sonoma-ish looking wood benches that looked like they belonged in 1890s, kind of park. Disguised as decoration, the new features were meant to make it harder for skaters to use the ledges or to cruise from one end of the park to the other. So they took away the wide open paved areas and tried to replace them
最后，在2002年，费城市长约翰·斯特里特（John Street）将滑板禁令推进了一步，并对公园进行了翻新。他们做的最主要的事情是移除了所有的花岗岩长椅，这些极好的适合滑板的元素，取而代之的是，你知道的，某种威廉索诺玛风格的木制长椅，看起来像是属于1890年代那种公园的风格。这些新设计伪装成装饰，旨在让滑手更难利用矮墙，或者从公园的一端滑行到另一端。因此，他们移除了宽阔开放的铺装区域，并试图用
with grassy spaces in between. You know adding some landscaping, adding an actual lawn was a good idea, but the design result was kind of horrible. It's just a very uncomfortable space and not a space that people want to use. People protested the renovations. There were rallies and newspaper articles. One story read, the mayor blindly took a root of time-honored Philadelphia tradition in destroying a source of pride and fame, harder and by its own citizens. A big skateboard shoe company called DC even offered up a million dollars to keep the park the way it was and to kind of offset any damages skaters might have done over the years.
它们之间的草地空间取代。你知道，增加一些绿化，增加真正的草坪是个好主意，但设计结果有点糟糕。这只是一个非常不舒服的空间，不是人们想要使用的空间。人们抗议翻新工程。有集会和报纸文章。一篇报道写道：“市长盲目地切断了费城历史悠久的传统，摧毁了由其自身市民创造的骄傲和名誉之源。”一家名为 DC 的大型滑板鞋公司甚至出资一百万美元，以保持公园原样，并用来抵消滑手多年来可能造成的任何损害。
The city of Philadelphia declined the offer. City counselors and architects like Tony spoke out too. I think there would have been a way to make some significant adjustments to love park that would accommodate other kinds of activities without totally compromising skateboarding and come up with a successful evolution of the space. I think that that would have been possible. I think politically it was, that would have been too difficult. Love Park drew people to the city. Philadelphia even hosted this big skateboard competition called the X Games, the two summers prior to getting rid of Love Park. But, you know, unlike traditional sports, skateboarding is kind of hard
费城市政府拒绝了这个提议。市议员和像托尼这样的建筑师也直言不讳。我认为本有一种方法可以对爱公园进行一些重大调整，以适应其他类型的活动，而不会完全损害滑板运动，并实现该空间的成功演变。我认为那是可能的。我认为从政治上讲，那会太困难了。爱公园吸引了人们来到这座城。在摆脱爱公园前的两个夏天，费城甚至举办了一场名为 X Games 的大型滑板比赛。但是，你知道，与传统运动不同，滑板运动有点难以
to control and difficult to monetize. And that's usually a little scary to the squares. But not to Ed Bacon. Bacon was thrilled that his space was evolving. Here he is from a 2006 documentary called Freedom of Space. would creatively adapt to the environment they already found. And that it was their joy to adapt themselves physically to what was already there. Bacon was so against the renovations and cracked down on skaters in his park he staged his own protest. On October 8th, 2002, with the media there, two
控制且难以变现。这通常会让保守派感到有点害怕。但埃德·培根并非如此。培根对他的空间在不断演变感到欣喜若狂。以下是他在2006年一部名为《空间的自由》的纪录片中的讲话。他们会创造性地适应他们已经找到的环境。他们的快乐在于使自己在身体上适应已经存在的东西。培根非常反对翻新并打击他公园里的滑手，他甚至组织了自己的抗议活动。2002年10月8日，在媒体在场的情况下，两
people propping him up on either side and a blue bicycle helmet on. A white hair trench coat clad 92-year-old Ed Bacon wrote a skateboard in Love Park. Held up and pushed along on a skateboard might be a more accurate description. And now I, Edmund Dunn-Bacon, in total defiance of Mayor Good Abghana, in total defiance of Mayor Street and the Council of the City of Philadelphia. Hereby, exercise my rights as the citizens of the United States, and I deliberately skate in my beloved love park. Woo!
个人在一旁扶着他，头上戴着一顶蓝色自行车头盔。一位白发苍苍、身穿风衣的92岁老人埃德·培根在爱公园玩起了滑板。被搀扶着并在滑板上被推着前进可能是更准确的描述。现在我，埃德蒙·邓恩·培根，完全无视市长古德·阿布加纳，完全无视市长斯特里特和费城市议会。在此，我行使作为美国公民的权利，在我深爱的爱公园里故意玩滑板。呜！
Oh, hold on. I can't see for my office. Oh, God! Thank you, thank you, thank you! My whole damn life has been worth it just for this moment. Man life has been worth it just for this moment. The ugly pink planters and William and Sonoma benches stole Grey Slow Park, but so does a plaque memorializing Ed Bacon and people still skateboard there
哦，等一下。我从办公室看不见。哦，天哪！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！为了这一刻，我整个该死的人生都值了。为了这一刻，我的人生都值了。丑陋的粉红色花坛和威廉索诺玛长椅毁了爱公园，但纪念埃德培根的牌匾也是如此，人们仍然在那里滑板
and they still get chased by cops. Skaters now figure out ways to work around the redesign. Something Ed Bacon would probably be proud of. Love Park isn't the iconic spot it used to be, but Skate Park started copying features from its original design. There's a good chance that if a skate park was built in your area in the last 10 years, it'll have a knee-high, modern-estile bench, or maybe even those same cascading long steps like the ones in Love Park. You'll also see things like hubbos like we talked about earlier or
并且他们仍然会被警察追赶。滑手们现在找到了绕过重新设计的方法。埃德·培根可能会为此感到骄傲。爱公园已经不再是过去那个标志性的地点了，但滑板公园开始模仿其原始设计的特色。很有可能，如果在过去10年里在你所在的地区建造了一个滑板公园，它就会有一个膝盖高的现代风格长椅，或者甚至可能有像爱公园那样连续的长台阶。你还会看到像我们之前讨论过的 hubba 或者
even a low block of concrete beside a small set of stairs. We call that a pure seven ledge named after another San Francisco spot. These are all design elements that were dreamt up by some well-meaning city planner and they're now worshipped by skaters. Tony, the architect we heard from, is now working on a skate friendly city plaza. That's right, near LoveFuck. I gotta admit, pardon me thinks these designated places to skateboard
甚至是一小段楼梯旁边的一块低矮的混凝土块。我们称之为“纯七矮墙”，以另一个旧金山地点命名。这些都是由某个好心的城市规划师梦想出来的设计元素，现在它们被滑手们顶礼膜拜。我们听到的那位建筑师托尼现在正致力于打造一个对滑板友好的城市广场。没错，就在 LoveFuck 附近。我必须承认，有时我认为这些指定的滑板地点
kinda miss the point. It's like running a marathon on a treadmill. It's not exactly the type of thing that'll get you on the cover of Runner's World. But guys like Tony are legitimizing skating to designers and architects. He gets it. A skate park is now something that real architects can have a hand in.
有点偏离重点。这就像在跑步机上跑马拉松。这绝对不是那种能让你登上《跑者世界》杂志封面的类型。但像托尼这样的人正在使滑板运动对设计师和建筑师来说合法化。他懂的。滑板公园现在成了真正的建筑师可以参与的事情。
But part of the excitement of street skating is happening upon that spot that wasn't meant to be skated, but seems like it was built exactly for a certain trick. It's like found art. That's why we're still hunting for spots in the streets. Pro skaters now fly out to China for three weeks at a time to skate the new sprawling marble plazas that seem to pop up there on a daily basis. And because skateboarding isn't as popular there, the war on skaters hasn't seemed to reach China yet. Modernist architecture appears,
但街头滑板的部分刺激之处在于，偶然发现那个本不是为了滑板而建、但看起来像是专门为某个特定技巧而建的地方。这就像是现成艺术。这就是为什么我们仍在街头寻找地点的原因。职业滑手们现在一次飞往中国三个星期，去滑那些似乎每天都在那里拔地而起的崭新大理石广场。而且由于滑板运动在那里不像那么受欢迎，针对滑手的“战争”似乎还没有蔓延到中国。现代建筑出现，
then skaters, then skate stoppers. And in a way, without really knowing it, we're kind of critiquing the design. Skaters say, we don't care what you made it for. This is how we're using it. And when you land a trick there, it's like a secret victory. You put your own Mark on a place. And now even us squares can read those marks, too. 99% Invisible with Produce this week by Andrew Norton. I don't know if a lot of radio shows really like to mention Smoking Crack at the front
然后是滑手，然后是防滑装置。在某种程度上，在不知不觉中，我们其实是在对设计进行批判。滑手们说：“我们不在乎你是为了什么而建造它的。这就是我们使用它的方式。”当你成功在那里完成一个技巧时，就像是一场秘密的胜利。你在一个地方留下了你自己的印记。现在连我们这些循规蹈矩的人也能读懂那些印记了。本周的《99% Invisible》由安德鲁·诺顿制作。我不知道很多广播节目是否真的喜欢在节目前面提到吸食快克海洛因
of their show. With help from Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars, It's a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars, but what pictures of hubbob hideouts, skaters bounding over love Park as photographed by Mike Playback and the amazing video of Edmund Bacon Define Authority on a skateboard courtesy of our friends at WHYY. Oh God! Thank you! Thank you! Thank you! It's all at 99%invisible.org.
在萨姆·格林斯潘和罗曼·马尔斯的帮助下，这是旧金山本地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7 和旧金山美国建筑师学会的一个项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞这个节目，我在 Twitter 上@Roman Mars，但是 Mike Playback 拍摄的 hubba hideouts 的照片、滑手们飞跃爱公园的照片，以及我们的朋友 WHYY 提供的埃德·培根在滑板上蔑视权威的精彩视频。哦，天哪！谢谢！谢谢！谢谢！一切尽在 99%invisible.org。
This, I feel like this, what Ed Bacon says here, should be like the pledge of allegiance for skateboarders. Like, whenever you go skateboard, you should be like, I, Andrew Norton, hereby exercise my right as a citizen of Canada, and I deliver really skateboard. Radio to you. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我觉得这个，埃德·培根在这里说的话，应该成为滑手们的效忠宣誓。就像，每当你去玩滑板时，你应该说：我，安德鲁·诺顿，在此行使我作为加拿大公民的权利，我确实要玩滑板。广播带给你。来自 PRX。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。